A lot of people like when they do,
you know,
like did you stand up?
They do jokes.
Is very few people telling like long
stories like you do that or the best
favorite shoe was that
like did the Berlin,
was that Berlin would do both.
He would mix it up.
He'd do and what not.
Jokes,
jokes.
Highland.
We do like one liners.
You know,
he did whatever he thought was funny.
Sam Kass and bill Cosby
though was probably the most
influential bill Cosby and
oddly enough,
Spalding gray.
Probably the most influential.
What happened to that guy?
Didn't he die?
He killed himself.
Yeah,
I think he,
well,
I think,
you know,
I don't know if he could
prove that sort of thing,
but they think he drowned
himself off the ferry.
He didn't get,
it obviously had a lot of issues,
issues and whatnot,
but I enjoy,
joy has his readings.
If you've never heard
or listened to theirs,
you can listen to terrors of pleasure,
monster and a box.
Of course he eats in a box,
came to prominence with a,
it was swimming to Cambodia but monster
and a box is fucking riveting and it's
literally a dude telling a
long story and I loved it.
It's like an hour and a half,
two hours maybe or something like great
to have something different like that
and he just let you sit
there and you can't,
I mean you can watch a video
version of that that believe exists,
but I always listened to
it and it was just magical.
The idea of like a dude who's essentially
telling one very long joke that's has
highs and lows,
emotional beats and makes
you sad and that gets real.
Like every once in a while he throws and
you're laughing and he'll just stop you
dead with like my mother
killed herself and you know,
Blah Blah Blah.
And he just derails the
comedy and you forget like,
Oh shit,
this dude's not a comic.
He's literally storytelling.
And so I appreciated
that and I appreciate it.
Bill Cosby,
my favorite comedy bits of all time is
the one side of that album to Russel,
my brother who has slept with it's,
I don't know if you've ever heard it,
but it's so fucking hysterical.
It's bill Cosby's I guess how long was
the side of a record back in the day for
40 minutes or something.
45 one side.
I don't remember.
30 member man maybe.
Cause he was,
he wouldn't flip sides when
you had a good long record.
Right Faye?
I'm want to say 30 minutes Max.
I don't know.
But this should be,
she Google this for somebody
going here in this room.
This piece is the whole side of an
album and it's essentially him telling a
story about him and his little
brother trying to go to sleep.
Um,
when they were kids and the
interplay with their father.
And it's so,
it is,
it's spellbinding like he paints the
picture puts you're right there in the
room.
He never curses.
Dude.
Never uses a sexual innuendo,
nothing.
Not Know are the tricks that like
if I had to do it straight like him,
I could never have done.
Never have done it.
Still can't do it to this day.
And he drops science for that entire bit.
It is,
it's brilliant.
It's so low.
It's hysterical.
He's absolutely adorable as the kids
and he's playing both of them and stuff.
Do yourself a favor,
listen to it.
That was very inspirational for me too.
I was like,
look,
I could do this if this
was kind of comedy.
I think I could do this.
If you could tell Lawrence Long stories,
even as chicken hearts shit,
the go cards bit is fat Albert Buck,
Buck and the ninth street bridge a bit.
Bill Cosby stuff is,
I know some people maybe
aren't into them now,
but oh my God,
before he did that show long,
even though I go listen to the albums,
the allies or even now today,
stand up is still great.
I've heard people that like Chris Rock
was on TV talking about it once about how
he'd just gone to see him.
And uh,
he was,
um,
I think it was in the movie comedian,
the Jerry Seinfeld movie.
Think that's what it,
so,
which wasn't that long ago,
10 years ago.
Said the costume,
he was still sharp.
He said,
he goes,
Chris Rock,
who's one of the greatest ever.
I was like,
I feel like a fraud.
He goes,
After watching them,
he goes,
he just went up no opener for like two
hours and he did two shows and you know,
Bill Cosby's elderly gentleman.
I was going to say at this point,
he's gotta be like 70
still up there killing it.
And the crazy thing is,
I don't even think he goes
anywhere to try shit out.
I think he just writes it
all down right to it at home,
you know?
And then he even said it like he does
stand up on the tonight show and he
literally doesn't practice the standup.
He goes,
I know what's funny.
I especially at now,
boy,
crazy is that like,
I know,
it's funny,
I'm just going to write
out my entire monologue.
He's a,
he's an old master.
You know,
Bill Cosby will be a great guy if someone,
I mean,
I wouldn't subscribe to all of his
principals because he's really into clean
comedy and I really appreciate
good dirty comedy too.
I'm sorry.
I appreciate good clean
comedy and like again,
he's a master master.
I can't do it,
but that's not my favorite.
I gotta be honest.
I,
if I had a choice between listening to
Kozian Kennison one of the reasons why we
choose Kennison is cause he would go deep.
He would go take me to crazy places.
And that's what I want to do.
I've got a couple of drinks in me.
I want,
I want to hear you talk about
Jesus's last might words,
but not my,
I mean,
I want to talk about Philly.
Yeah.
Talk about like heat.
The relationship shit he did was really,
really fucking Carlin Carlin and his
book and that sort of biography book.
I think he talks about Kennison.
Either that or I was watching an
interview the Carlin did with,
um,
uh,
John Stewart before he was just,
or Jon Stewart.
Um,
for some anniversary or some
maybe it aspen comedy fest,
and he said that Kennison was the
one that made him step his game up.
Wow.
Karlyn was just like,
when I see he's a very
rarely to like a comic,
like bomb away,
but he loved comics,
but Kinison was the one that made him go,
oh shit.
Like I should have,
why didn't I do that?
You know,
why don't you move to
where the fucking food is?
Did you ever read his brother's book?
No.
How is it?
It's awesome.
It's called Bro.
My brother Sam is very Sam,
very honest,
very honest and very,
very insightful.
But one of the things that he says is it,
Sam got hit by a car
when he was a little boy,
I think it was a truck
and after he got hit,
he was never the same kid again.
All of a sudden he was angry and reckless.
So he literally became Sam Kennison
because they got hit by a car.
They said before that it
was like a normal kid.
But then after he got hit,
all of a sudden became like reckless
and wild,
which sometimes happens when
people have head injuries.
That's a,
yeah,
that is crazy because a head injury
might've created one of the greatest
comedians in the history
of the known universe.
Right.
For Real.
It's true.
It's crazy to think
because he was so wild.
Man.
Silent.
Bob Wears a coat.
Like I wore that trench coat
because of Sam Kennison.
Really?
Oh my God.
I love that.
That's awesome.
And I had a poster in my room as a kid,
like he had done,
I don't even know how they
fucking got him to do this,
but they had in school,
this is,
they started this in school,
advertise and shit.
Even back then we're talking 1988 and
they'd have billboards where they would
put posters in where there was some
celebrity talking about read and it was
sponsored by some fucking company
and should everyone made out somehow.
But ultimately the message was good.
Whatever the message was meant to be
for high school or passing by in the
hallway.
Sam Kennison was on one of them.
And to think about that Sam Kinison
and inspirational high school poster.
It was just kind of,
if you've no Sam kinisons work at all,
it's just lunacy.
Wow.
I don't know how it happened.
He must have had a hell of an
agent or manager who's like,
I got you this Gig.
And I dunno if anyone remembers it,
but May.
But I remember I was a huge fan.
I'd seen him on Snl,
like he did that fucking crushing.
I'd seen him around the
Rodney Dangerfield special,
but on SNL he came out and he fucking,
they had to bleep them and shit like that.
He was legendary already.
And there he was in this poster.
And I remember going to
the principal and be like,
can I have this when they take it down?
And so he gave me the poster and I had
it in my room for the longest time.
And even though it was like
he couldn't curse on it,
it was about,
you know,
fucking doing your best or whatever,
being your own person.
It was classic Kinison Yell Pose,
you know,
of the,
ah,
so I had it in my room.
I start wearing trench coats because
Kennison he made a little Paris.
We went up to New York City to when they,
uh,
in Manhattan down in the village.
Was that place like vintage,
not vintage vinyl.
I'd be a record store,
but it was about clothes,
old clothes,
vintage clothes and bought
old trench coats and shit.
Trying to look like Sam Kinison.
Wow.
Is there a return of Jay and silent
Bob in the work anytime ever?
No.
We do the podcast now.
We've kind of taken the
character's and turn them into,
I guess title more than anything else.
Did you ever have a script for it?
And like,
I like another one.
There was like,
no,
there was no script for it.
But like every once in a
while you'd muse about like,
well maybe this would
be funny or I'd do this.
And they started getting more and more
ridiculous and that's what I knew it was
time to stop.
Plus we're getting older.
It's kind of tough to pull
that off at like fucking,
I love it.
40 yeah,
did,
but don't rule it out.
If you smoke a fatty one day and you're
sitting in a Jacuzzi and he goes,
it's the character.
I'd like to get to see the character.
You can do that in cartoon form.
I would love to live forever.
That's true.
It's easier,
but I would love to see it
from the place where you're at.
You know?
I would love
to see you.
I don't eat none of it.
That's the,
I don't know.
That might be the danger.
Like Jane Silent.
Bob were not written by a stoner,
and at least that's what I learned
to ask you about at that point.
You know,
maybe they don't work if
they're written by a stoner.
I interrupted you earlier
when you were talking about,
we were talking about the,
you know,
what's the difference now?
You know,
and that three years later,
like now you're,
you've been smoking weed for how long now?
I started 30 38 1938 no,
no.
Page 38 so that was,
I'm sorry,
1998 yeah,
nine he started in 98 that's when
you really started smoking weed.
No,
I'm sorry,
2008 I have 2008 years off.
Yeah.
I was baffled because I thought I'd
heard that Seth Rogan got you into it.
That was a,
I was doing the math in my head going,
wait a second,
I leave off.
Hire you.
You left off very at all.
God Damn Day.
I'm bad at math,
but B,
I skipped a decade in
my head all the time.
All the time.
You,
Oh God,
I forget to do that on checks.
No,
just when the conversation always in
talking about something where I'm like,
oh,
but that was like 90 something.
They're like Kevin.
Then we had a whole decade and now
we're into a new decade cause you start,
once you start getting to the bubbly
start making entertainment there,
there is no more calendar
for either schedules,
you know,
shooting,
scheduled,
but ain't no more calendar.
You don't look at the calendar the way
everybody else does and the idea of 2000
still hard to sink in and then 2011 what?
Really?
2000 seems like we're
living in the future.
You remember that ACDC Song?
No,
no.
Ace freely song,
don't you know,
my two Railey's comment,
ace freely,
uh,
was I think it was on his solo,
when he was a with kiss and
they all branched off into Solo.
Right.
But talk at singing about
some guy in the future.
He was singing about a 2000 man guy
flying around jet cars and shit.
You know,
I remember being,
I was born in 70 and so it was very
easy to do the math because you know,
every 10 years you were,
whatever the decade was,
you were kind of giving kind of be
that age or at least have the number
involved.
So I would always say like
I'm in in the year 2000,
I'll be 30.
Cause I could do that for simple math.
And that seemed like such
a far way fucking concept.
And now we're 11 years past it.
Yeah.
Like the oldest I thought I
could ever imagined I could be.
I tell people I'm 44
and then I have to go,
Ooh,
that's not good.
It doesn't matter anymore.
How much longer is this going to last?
Yeah.
Well when it does matter manage,
you know,
pain or no,
he's still in very good shape and I
take care of my Iranian or work out,
but I have to,
if I don't take care of it,
it drops off quick.
Now that's what I'm noticing.
If I get injured and I can't work
out for a couple of weeks now,
whoa.
When I come back it's like I'm
fucking starting from scratch man.
I come back,
I'm a pussy like,
like really?
Just two weeks,
two weeks I lose like half of my cardio.
It's crazy.
Two weeks you get exhausted like really
quickly and it's like you have to build
your body back to some sort of artificial
level of functionality in order to do
like martial arts and things at my age.
And if you don't,
it's not going to work anymore.
You Shit starting to
break son a year a year,
your artificial
functionality must look like,
I must look like the bionic
man compared to my best,
absolute best,
the focus thing.
I just been doing it since I was like,
I started doing martial arts
when I was a real little kid.
So by the time I was 15 years old
when I really got really got obsessed,
I was,
I was in the sophomore year of high
school and that's when I really,
really truly got obsessed
with martial arts.
From that time.
I've always been training.
That's a long time.
Think about it.
Yeah,
it's for me it's like,
you know,
some people go and they play basketball.
Some people go and you know,
they'll,
they'll the meet some friends and
they'll go play golf together.
I go and do Jujitsu.
To me it's an,
it's a normal thing.
It's like it's,
you know,
going to and training in martial arts,
it's like,
you know,
it's how I get my aggressions out.
It's how I straightened my mind out.
At the end of the day.
It's how,
when you know,
when you're in the face of something very
difficult like sparring with someone,
when you're doing Jiu Jitsu sparring,
you're forced into this
sort of a moving meditation,
sort of a,
a zone.
You know,
where you can only think
about what you're doing.
You have to figure out a way to manage
your resources because you're in a hand
to hand combat battle with a skilled man,
right?
And you guys are going back and forth
to each other and you try to choke each
other and it's very intense.
But in doing that very intense thing,
you lose yourself in the movements and
you hit this sort of a zen state and you
can only hold it for like a certain
amount of time for you get fucking
exhausted.
And the key,
the key is holding that moment
for as long as possible.
Keeping it going for as long as possible.
So you gotta do like strength
and conditioning and Chin
ups and dips and fucking
kettlebells and all this shit is just
to get in there so you can go deeper and
deeper with the Jujitsu
so he can tap people.
When you were in tapping him,
avoid being tapped when
you were getting tapped.
So you,
you have to tune you.
It's almost like your effort and your
will is what powers your race car.
Instead of just being able to,
you know,
go to the track and get a new
engine or whatever the fuck you do.
You know your effort and your will
determine what your physical body can do.
So it's this crazy game that you get
stuck and get addicted to and this game is
just seniors and you're fucking love it.
I love learning new shit,
man.
I love working with different kickboxing
trainers and learn a new shed because
when you,
when you learn anything,
I believe it elevates everything.
I really believe that.
I believe that the more excellence you
can get in your body and your mind in
your day,
the better everything is.
I think that the better you'll feel,
the better you'll be.
You know,
you'll,
you'll project better energy out there.
You'll be nicer to people,
they'll be nice with you.
I really believe that.
I think in getting great at something,
in finding,
even if just attempting
to improve at something,
you're always going towards
the right direction.
You're always using positive energy.
You are always using discipline.
You always getting results
in improving anything.
When you see those results
that reinforces this,
this in in you,
you and your whole existence to push
forward and be positive and create and,
and resolve things and figure
things out and reach your pinnacle.
You know?
So I think all that stuff like
that's why I got this tattoo.
I think it's all connected.
What is it?
The book of the Seven
Ring Book of five rings.
Fiber,
the Moto moto-massage
you fucking rings in the,
yeah.
Maybe you're the fucking next
guy going to contribute to it.
What is the subway way?
What are the explaining the title?
The five ranks?
No,
I don't know.
You'd have to like
really get into her nod.
I don't,
I don't know what he's,
this dude was a Ronin.
Yeah,
he was around how to,
a story on what happened and African
banks bitches and writes poetry for real.
It just got tired of Chubb and
be Blob and he wrote a book.
That was it.
He was just like,
you know,
I killed a lot.
Now I'm just going to,
yeah.
I wrote a book on how to be a carpenter
and how to be a fucking philosopher and
had to be in anything
really follow that book.
It's an amazing book
if you can figure out,
you see,
it's so hard when you translate from
Japanese to American to really know his
words.
You would really have to learn Japanese
and understand the difference in the,
you know,
the way things are worded.
You know when you translate you,
you get a rough estimate
of what the guy was saying.
It would have to be in the context of his
culture and you take it in the context
of the context of the time that he existed
and it's an amazing insight into an
exceptional individual.
It's an amazing insight into like a guy
who had reached a height clearly that no
one around him had with
this sword fighting thing,
which is so intense and that you,
you,
there's no room for
bullshit and sword fighting.
You can't pretend you're
better than you are.
There's no bullshitting.
There's no need to talk shit.
Okay,
this is all going down with steel.
That's going to be moving at like 50
miles an hour towards your fucking face.
Yeah.
You got to be absolutely 100%
sure of the correct technique.
How to do,
how to avoid and get in there and
get your shit done and survive.
This is not tennis bitch.
That's insane.
To live a life like that,
finding people with fucking swords
until we've done it successfully.
I think it was 62 times it was the number
that he supposedly killed and then be
like,
it's time to become a writer.
Could you imagine somebody put publishes
that book and somebody gives them a bad
review?
It's just like there's occasionally,
there's a guy like that that
will exist in martial arts.
There's these occasional guys that will
stand out above and beyond all the rest.
Hixon Gracie is the last one.
He's the the the premier
member of the Gracie family.
You know the Gracies.
You ever heard of them for the
ultimate fighting championship?
Now you're completely out of the loop.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm bear on virgin month.
Wow.
I knew there was people
like you out there.
I knew.
I'd heard it up,
but that's,
that's not even just for
UFC or mixed martial arts.
Any spots,
any sports beyond hockey,
hockey do,
but everything else like you know,
they'll be like,
oh,
this guy,
they,
and they'll say a name and it's a name
that I've heard for fucking years,
but I don't know what sport the Duplos.
What made you,
what made you be this?
Um,
what did that way?
Yeah.
What made you be
broken?
All your,
look,
I'm the worst.
Here's mine.
Professional Pool and fighting.
That's it.
That's all I watched.
That's awesome.
I don't know anything else.
If you are a guy in another sport,
either you have to talk a lot of shit
like that Oto Cinco guy or you have what
is,
get arrested for something.
What does he play?
He's a football player.
Okay.
I was going to guess base and then Michael
Vick gets arrested for killing dogs,
so I know who he,
yeah,
totally.
Definitely the infamous Oj Simpson.
I've heard this.
I heard of that guy.
Yeah.
This,
like if they're,
you're not a boxer or a kickboxer,
but I know some obscure little
Japanese guys at fight and some,
you know,
weird circuit over in Japan.
I know,
I know I've done the name of
a lot of different fighters.
I've caught a lot of that
information in my head.
But no sports guys
never had that.
Never been a sports dude,
wasn't it?
But you are because you're your hockey.
Like I could say I'm
not a sports do either,
but I obviously am cause
I'm into mixed martial arts.
I'm more about the philosophy
of hockey than anything else.
What does this mean for
as a more as an idea,
as an idea I the philosophy of hockey,
I mean as it's kind of
the philosophy of life.
You have a goal.
Someone's in your way,
don't let them stop you.
Score.
Like that's just the very base clear.
I don't think it needs to go much deeper.
I think that's kind of the
beauty of the poetry of it.
Now you tie that to one
of the most graceful,
beautiful games on the planet and
played with physical excellence.
I mean,
I understand it.
You need to be on your fucking game to
step into a ring with a dude who could
fucking kill you with his fist.
But when you dial it
down to a game that's,
you know,
less lethal and stuff and more just
about moving a ball or a puck around that
sport takes is probably the greatest
athleticism I think to play any sport.
Because think about it
just to stand in skates,
you're using more muscles than most
people actually use on a regular basis.
So even if you're not
doing anything in the game,
you are ready.
You have to be athletically
inclined just to stand there.
Now add to it,
they play tops.
What two minutes shifts?
Usually some one minute
shifts to hardcore.
Think about how hard you have to
skate in order to go back and forth.
Think about the running that you'll do
on a football field or basketball court.
Rather.
Let's go with the basketball court.
Um,
you know its foot on trial.
You're used to running.
Now try that with skates now.
Stop now go back quick now wait,
go back the other way.
You're puck chasing the whole time.
Like that's why they have those quick
shifts because who could stand that?
You have to be so physically in shape
to do that and it's beautiful to watch
people do that beautiful
graceful look like shit.
You know they're skating across the
giant diamond or some such shit,
you know?
And they're on water.
There's this miracle,
this element of like,
what do you mean it's water?
Like it's water,
but it's hard water.
You know?
It's just everything about
it really speaks to me.
It's fine.
Damn you making me a hockey fan.
I'm ready to go watch some fucking hockey.
It's humble too.
You know what I'm saying?
Like hi hockey played.
Most athletes are very fucking like,
you know a big shades on and they don't
want to talk to cameras and stuff.
Lotta a Lotta,
a lot of dramatics and whatnot.
Hockey players aren't like that at all.
Hockey players,
man,
you never have to hunt a
hockey player down for a quote.
I think when you're,
I think most journalists will tell you
that like their whole philosophy is very,
it's not like any philosophy here in
regards to baseball or football or any
other sport.
Philosophy is as simple sell the game.
That's it.
Sell the game.
The,
Oh,
the idea of passing the game onto what?
I just did a few seconds go.
I sold the game so much.
So they were like,
yeah,
I want to see that.
That sounds good.
Somebody should take a clip
and somebody will take,
take a clip of this and put it on the
Internet and use it as a promo for hockey.
It should know.
No,
she got way more famous before
and it'll pay attention.
You have to be way more famous.
Thanks.
So before people,
that's hilarious.
How famous do you think?
You are not aware.
Oh,
are you crazy?
Listen,
you're famous as fuck dude.
Now yes.
Now listen.
I know it's uncomfortable and you want
to be all underground and shit though.
You have a is Ben Affleck.
I have stood besides Ben Affleck
and that's fucking famous.
That's crazy money.
That's ridiculous.
Superstardom you're not that.
But you're famous as fuck.
It's a difference.
You're famous is,
fuck everyone I know knows who you are.
That's ridiculous.
You can't be so rarely is.
It would be silly.
I know you want to be humble,
but you're being silly.
You're famous as fuck.
I don't know.
I think most people like go,
oh,
he looks familiar,
but I don't think people
know they know your name.
Then you're famous is,
fuck.
I don't think anybody knows.
I think our name is so crazy.
Forget your cute.
That's cute.
Now come on,
dude.
It's not a recognized body.
Your mind.
My mom knows who you are.
So many people in this life go,
oh,
I love,
I love you on fucking King of Queens,
Kevin James.
You know what I'm saying to me,
so that's retards.
You're going to get retarded.
No matter where you go.
They're an unavoidable,
can't factor them into the equation.
You get hit by a random asteroid.
That's what that is.
When someone comes up to you,
cause you Kevin,
James,
rare medieval happened not too many
occasions for me to feel comfortable.
You know,
I fuck up with people's names too.
I'm always confusing one
person with another person.
I'm like,
Oh yeah,
really shit,
you know,
but that's,
I'm literally still dying
inside because I was thinking,
oh my God,
it was our wardrobe person's name,
Beth and I almost said Beth
Pasternak and I'm like,
is that her name?
And because that's one,
remember your login you to stone.
I wouldn't call it two stone,
but I a stoned enough.
Yeah,
you give,
if you're going to commit to a lifestyle,
you,
you give up on short term a
lot where you're just like,
I'm going to need help.
Like I do that a lot.
I find you've are fine.
I don't know how if you
ever do this on stage,
but I tell such long fucking convoluted
stories that invariably wants twice per
night.
Now I'll be in the middle of
something and just be like,
um,
like I,
I don't freeze it.
Don't get scared anymore,
but I just literally go,
the fuck was I talking about?
I'm so sorry.
And someone will be like,
ah,
it was Jerry Muse in a bathtub.
I'm like,
Oh yes,
thank you anyway.
And boom right back in as long as they
can help you out as long as they're there
to help.
But if not,
do there moments where you're just like,
oh my God.
Like I was on the tonight show earlier
and I sat down to tape the tonight show
and I wasn't nearly
stoned enough for that.
I wish I'd been more stone cause I would
have enjoyed it more the whole time I'm
sitting there just thinking
like I look fat on the show.
I know I look fat right now.
I know look fat.
And in the midst of it,
I did have those moments
where I wasn't stone,
but at a moment where I was like,
what the hell was I talking tonight?
Show you have one of those moments.
Yeah.
Luckily I connected it quickly,
but I love doing it onstage.
I used to be like,
oh,
you can't let people know.
And I'm like,
yeah,
and let's be realistic.
Like,
Hey,
I'm 41 I'm in the middle of a fucking
labyrinthine story to begin with.
There's so many moving parts and B,
it's see you throw some
weed on top of that.
You know,
every once in a while maybe a gear is
going to slip and you're going to forget a
detail,
but as long as the audience
is there to rescue you,
it's all good.
I love the fact that
you're honest about it.
You know,
there's a lot of people that aren't honest
about the positive effects of it and
they treat it like it's a trivial thing.
Oh,
you know,
when I,
when I was,
one of the things that I was
upset with Dr drew about,
and I,
and I do really love Dr drew,
but he's like,
oh,
you want to go smoke your weed?
Smoking weed?
You know,
like you say,
look,
I'm not telling you not to do it,
but it's dismissive about
it being a positive thing.
It's always like,
yeah,
you want to go do whatever
you want to do with your life.
I'm for freewill.
I'm for you having a good time.
And if you want to ruin your thing and go,
go right ahead.
I'm for,
but that's not your,
you're not taking to account all the
people that talk about these amazingly
positive benefits of the half
from it and you're one of them.
You know,
you're always talking
about mine medicine man.
I it and some people be like,
oh,
it just what it is.
It fuel your creativity as a no,
quite the opposite.
Like I don't think I've ever gotten a
new idea from weed that I wouldn't have
had otherwise.
What we'd allows you to
do is chase the good idea,
uh,
and embrace it rather than let it go for
fear that someone will judge it or for
fear that it won't work or hey,
this hasn't been done yet.
So I find weed doesn't make me
creative as much as it knocks down the
inhibitions that block creativity.
Like the reason you don't go further
on that cool idea because you're afraid
it's going to be judged or won't turn out
or who will ever buy this or what am I
thinking?
Or I can't pull something
like this off weed.
You could smoke away.
Those inhibitions is a very important
man that no matter how long we're here to
push down all those,
even the dopiest fucking fears,
the things that you're like,
anything in the boxes you in,
like you're talking about.
People like to sometimes keep that
box tighter and tighter to your eyes,
but it's more important to
kind of understand why things
happen and who invented
it,
what makes it work,
so to speak,
get to the bottom of it.
And weed makes you more introspective.
It really does.
You start looking and you start thinking,
you start to elders.
It creates time for me and
it creates time to think.
We have cannabinoid
receptors in our brain.
Oh,
I love the scope.
Go Yoda stoned to THC.
You know,
we know that human use of THC
goes back at least 10,000 years.
We,
we,
you know,
we've,
we're constantly finding like old
mummies with bags of weed with them.
You know,
there's,
there's people that believe that it had
some part of the evolution of language,
you know,
and explain the idea of
this cannabinoids receptors.
All right.
The idea that you've got receptors in
your brain tuned in to give you eggs to
tune into exactly what this
marijuana plant is getting.
Only that they do nothing else,
but that was the also they also,
I think cannabinoids can be fired
up when you that runner's high too.
I think somehow.
I know that that's very soon.
You are the one telling me this far.
I think it was when you were on the show,
you were going and telling me like the
the drug or the brain kicks in with
something when you're about to die.
They said,
well,
they believe it.
It's called dimethyltryptamine.
It's produced by the liver,
the lungs,
and they believe it's
produced by the pineal gland.
They're actually doing these spa like
super specific studies on this shit right
now because throughout all eastern
mysticism they've always talked about the
third on that image.
Right?
Of course.
Well that is where the pineal gland rests
and it literally is an eyeball on that
from that HP Lovecraft movie from beyond,
they were going after the pineal glands.
A little fucking thing came out.
Well,
the crazy thing about that gland is that
in certain reptiles and actually has a
retina in a lens like
it's a fucking eyeball,
it is.
It is an eyeball and in they believe
that this is what they call it,
the seat of the soul.
They believe it is the
factory of the most potent,
naturally produced psychedelic chemicals.
We don't know what exactly because you
have to cut into the fucking brain like
within 15 minutes of someone
being dead to find it.
I think there's some,
some crazy roadblock to finding out
exactly what today's technology,
where the the DMT is being
manufactured in the brain,
so they're trying to figure out an invent
new technology to directly monitor it
so they can absolutely prove
it even if they don't prove it.
Where,
where it's manufactured.
It's known that it exists in the body.
It's known that it's produced by several
different organs and it is known that
it's intensely psychedelic.
W what I found comforting about that
was the way you presented it was in the
moment that you are dying,
your body knows that
and sends it in doses.
Huge.
Just send me an angel.
Yes,
bitch.
It just dopes you and
the fuck out the edge.
That notion that my body is like mad.
Nah,
he ain't going to handle
this Chubby can't handle it.
He's going to need to shut down.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
And then the doors of perception
open up like fucking giant exploding
kaleidoscopes of insane light with no
boundary and you get shot through a
fucking tunnel.
Just like a DMT trip.
Don't give transported into
the center of the universe.
How many psychedelic
experiences have you had?
Never.
I mean what?
What?
Explain mushrooms.
No,
don't do that.
I've never done that.
But you're like,
wait.
Yeah,
I do.
And I'm not even judgemental about it.
Like I can't say that people that do,
but I've never done it.
I don't know if it would,
I don't know how I would handle that.
Oh,
you have much to learn.
Grasshopper.
We were ready to straighten you out.
I don't know if that's
Mckenna building goes,
but like the floor I'm on is
frightening enough but manageable.
I can't imagine what it's like.
Well,
98 three years.
You're just sort of coming to
grips with the whole thing.
You know that your,
your whole life is greatly enhance and
far more fascinating when you're high.
And then you start thinking about,
well,
why aren't more people talking about
the benefits of this incredible drug and
why is it being demonized?
And you start processing in your mind.
And Mushrooms are that times a million
and den Dmt is mushrooms times a million
plus aliens.
So that's what it is.
It's like,
does anyone come back?
Yeah,
man,
I'm,
maybe you gotta be a weak bitch,
but you might get lost.
I'm not scared of the woods,
Bro.
I go out in the woods,
I'll go out in the woods to
learn something about myself.
And that's what it is.
It's like every,
every intense psychedelic experience is
like what year the benefits that you're
getting from,
um,
marijuana is like a slow IV drip,
right?
This is like someone's sticking a fucking
Turkey based or up your asshole and
shoving it.
Scary lunging into your
central nervous system.
Well,
it's supposed to be scary
because as you said,
when you heard that your
father scream to death,
you only get one shot at this,
you know,
and that,
that fear is the fear of losing control,
which is absolutely inevitable.
You know,
and you know it,
I know it.
And that you did with the
psychedelic experiences or like,
it's like,
it allows you to almost go through
a death experience several times.
Not to the point where you feel dead,
but to the point where you're,
your whole view of the
world is so shattered.
Your ego is so you,
your,
your actual worth in your actual piece
in this puzzle is made so clear and it's
so humbling and it's so confusing
and it's so enlightening and it's so
encouraging and it's so loving and it's
so frightening all at the same time,
all impossible to describe the images and
the feeling you get literally probably
are responsible for human evolution.
And there's some that game,
Terence Mckenna believe that the reason,
and he had at this,
this documented down to climate change.
He believed that the reason why human
beings evolved from other hominids is that
they started experimenting with new food
sources and eating siliciden mushrooms
and he has it all down to when the,
the rain forest receded and became
grasslands cause the climate change.
That's when the monkeys ran out of
food and they started in grasslands.
It's not as rich as the rain forest.
So they had to fucking experiment new
food sources and that's when all these
cows were walking around eating the glass.
The grass cow shit out.
The Shit Shit grows mushrooms
on a monkeys eat the mushrooms,
monkeys figure out all kinds of different
shit like language and coordination
and how to make tools and how to fucking
throw rocks at things and killed them
tools.
We were just on the know
somebody that's a tool.
No,
but my wife told him this story,
if I fucking capture my imagination
was just kind of write up the salad.
You see this dolphin story
about the conch shells?
No.
Oh,
they use them to fish?
Yes.
Yeah,
I did hear about that.
How fucking spell Vinings that these
dolphins are taking these conch shells,
which that was the second most
surprising thing about the story.
To me there was a picture,
it's conch shells.
Fucking huge mega conch shells
is like being like this,
but it's funny.
So that's the thing like Whoa,
why in any event these dolphins,
they found them like they thought they
used to go under the conch shells to fish
out anything that wasn't live
in their fish or what have you.
But they've discovered that
they're using them as tools,
as trapping tools,
like using them to kind of heard fish
and then cup Lum and then eat out of it.
So using them to capture and to
dig and like not and very specific,
not just like,
oh he's balancing a conch shell.
They're using it.
They're,
they're figuring tools out.
Yeah.
How to dolphins get so
fucking smart without thumbs.
It's really interesting
when you think about it,
cause no separators in the ocean
and you don't have to open the door.
They're supposed to be really intelligent.
Like,
we don't exactly know how
intelligent and some people,
because I think their cerebral cortex
is some large percentage larger than a
human beings,
like something like 40%
larger than a human beings.
They have.
What would that mean?
I don't know if they've
been on a no reason better.
I don't know.
No,
I don't think so.
I think they just have like
such a different world as
far as their coordination
and their physical movement and a like
neanderthal had a bigger brain than a
human bang and one of the,
and they were done with us for sure,
but they needed a bigger brain
operate that fucking ridiculous body.
Like neanderthals were
very different than people.
There were five foot,
two,
200 pounds of solid muscle and bone.
There were these big
like half chimp people,
you know,
like if you look at like,
like drawings of the [inaudible],
like they don't really resemble,
I mean they do,
but they don't do legs and
two other standing up right
of they would have fucked
us up if it was just like one on one
brawls between the underdogs and people.
Most likely neanderthals
would've fucked us up.
Yeah.
There's some,
this is some serious genetic,
what was I talking about?
Why did I talking about man,
that's what it sounds like.
Yeah.
What was I talking about?
You're talking about a neanderthal man.
Big Brain needed big brain
to operate that big body.
Oh,
sorry.
Okay.
It's dolphins.
Brains are larger.
It could be just to operate
that incredible body they have.
You just hit a pothole and my friend.
Yeah.
Good.
Thank you for [inaudible] to save.
Yeah,
thank you.
And that's what is the beautiful thing
about letting the audience know that
you're high and when
you do those Q and A's,
do you let them know,
listen,
I just need you as a net.
The nice thing about always talking about
being stone is people that just assume
that at all times you are.
So there's a nice blanket for everything.
Did you ever get to the point when
you first started getting high?
We,
you got too high and
he got really paranoid.
Not Paranoid is quit.
No,
not quit,
but I thought I'd died when
I thought I was going to die.
I got really stoned with my friend Jim
Jackman and he came over and we were out
on the deck at my house.
It's night out,
stars and shit sitting there smoking and
I had already spoke before he got there
and then he came and I was like,
oh,
spoke another one.
This is in the days before
I would smoke that much.
So two joints within
the span of like what?
An hour and a half or something like that
and by the time I got to burn down to
the bottom of the second one,
I was like really,
really,
really fucked up.
And I kept telling him,
I was like,
I think this is it.
I got a late,
I gotta lay down like I,
I think my heart might stop tonight.
And he's like,
you want me to do anything?
I was like,
no,
let me just lay down.
I laid down next to the pool,
just on the deck looking up
at the stars and I was like,
I'm too high,
dangerously high.
I don't know what was,
I'd never really experienced that again.
Will that then what do you think it was?
Well,
first of all,
you probably wasn't
babbling heart expanding
the movie.
Is that what I have?
My mother never told me he's a silly,
do I get to fuck Murcia till mag as well.
That was that.
Was that what it was?
The boy had a bamboo in heart.
He get to,
he had a bad heart and in his parents
told me that at baboons they told me
those rookie highs,
you don't really achieve those,
those rookie highs.
Once you get a tolerance,
those rookie highs are like getting
shot into the center of the universe.
Chris Mcguire and when we got Chris
Mcguire high one night behind the comedy
store,
do you remember the story?
You were there with me.
We were Chris when Chris is a buddy of
mine from way back who've never gets
high.
He's a comic and it usually
has a couple of beers that's,
he'll get high if you're forced them too.
All right,
I'll take a hit of this.
He was a stone cold rookie
and he took two hits of was.
It was probably trainwreck cause
that's all we ever smoke is ridiculous.
Super space philosopher weed.
And then I came back to him
like 20 minutes later it goes,
Yo,
I got a problem.
I've got a real problem here.
He goes,
this is not,
we need somebody puts
something in this man.
I,
I'm,
this is somebody puts something in this.
I'm telling you,
this is not pot.
I've been hunting before.
This is not pot.
This is serious,
man.
I'm serious.
Somebody puts something in this.
I'm like,
no dude,
dude,
the weeds,
they'll eat that good.
And he was like,
no way.
That can't be real.
He didn't believe it.
Didn't believe it
because that rookie high,
the rookie high is,
it's terrifying.
I mean,
you might as well be on ecstasy.
It might as well be an asset.
I,
I can't say that I miss it though.
Like I enjoy,
I never feel,
I always said I don't get stoned.
That's for teenagers.
I get centered.
I enjoy where I get now.
Great Place,
great for conversation,
great for,
like I said,
knocking over d inhibitions and whatnot.
Um,
I'm not quite,
I don't know if I'm ready
to open the third eye,
but if,
if anyone's sold me closer to that,
you don't need to do it.
Nobody needs to do anything,
man.
That's all nonsense.
You can find your own place.
They need to give it a shot,
but it sounds appetizing.
I mean it's like,
look,
I'm a,
I am something of a journey or now and
at the end of the day it's not that far
removed.
We're not talking.
If he's not that,
you would go on like you should
do some bumps and fucking rails.
Dude,
you're talking about another thing
that's very close to what I'm doing.
It's very much the same
as as what you're doing.
It's all the same thing.
It's,
it's forcing you to shake like,
can I make a milk orange juice thing?
Where are you crying to an orange.
You want to eat it?
It gets really crazy because
it lasts for like six hours.
This is like a slow DMT release.
What do you do with it though?
You get,
if you eat it,
you have to eat it with an Mao inhibitor
and you've got to know something else.
How to brew that correctly.
It's like you can't eat it when you,
oh,
when you or at when you take it in oral
ACC DMT exists apparently in so many
different plants that our body has
a builtin defense mechanism for it.
It's called Mano aiming oxidase.
So when you eat something like say
if you eat grass that has DMT in it,
like sheep,
if they eat that grass will die.
It's really kind of crazy.
Like sheep.
If eat grass has DMT in it,
they just fucking fall in their bag and
stick their legs up and they tremble in
the air.
It's really kind of Nutty,
but human beings have figured out a way
to process it in our stomachs and that's
what this motto Amy unoxidized says.
That's why we can eat it in
so many different plants,
but yet it's not psychoactive.
What these guys in the Amazon,
they figured out a way to make
it psychoactive when he eat it.
By combining this plant that as
this one drug with an Mao inhibitor,
so it kills the monoamine oxidase and
your stomach and it allows your stomach to
absorb this drug directly.
So you have to take something
in order to Hugh can,
you're going to be in the jungle.
There's no refrigerators.
Dude.
This is all bad.
It's a big step.
Let's go.
You gotta be a real seeker
if you want to do this.
Wait,
I thought we got,
I'm not sure.
That's the oral DMT mosquito Kosha.
That's the oral DMT.
What do you mean all my sermons first?
Don't even go.
Wait,
what is the mind mushroom?
You Chew Right?
Yeah.
You just need a little mushrooms.
You can make your first trip.
Could I'd make like a
strawberry milkshake mushroom.
You can eat it with the
same amount of people.
Like it won't be like,
oh no it,
you really shouldn't have
food in your stomach.
But as long as that is the only food that,
and it'll be like probably
diminish the effects,
vary slightly,
but ultimately it's all going
to get into your bloodstream.
It's good.
Did you ever have a bad trip,
bad trips or uh,
uh,
they're,
they're actually,
uh,
and it doesn't seem like it at the time,
but they're actually almost all beneficial
as long as you don't go completely
crazy.
What you learned from a bad trip
is that you've got some issues,
man.
You got some shit that's bugging you.
You got some,
some,
she's got some imbalances in your
mind and you are not focusing on them.
That's usually what it is and it comes
up or it's facing nightmarish form.
It comes up in nightmarish clarity.
That's what psychedelic experiences really
do it when you have something that's
really fucking with you,
that it's,
it's such a primary focus inside your
mind that when you open up these doors to
psychedelic dimensions,
your mind is going to grab that shit
and shove it in your face and go,
what the fuck is this?
Why you hiding this from?
Why don't you get this
shit out of the way?
Why do you think Oscar de la Hoya came
clean and said that he was wearing
women's underwear and those photos?
Then it was a real,
because every night that the fucking
truth is knocking them on the head,
Dude,
you were in
checks,
underwear.
Just fucking say it.
I can't,
he can take care of just
tossing and sweating.
If he ate a pot Brownie,
he would have been forced to admit it
like right away he just would have been
two down strips you down,
you know,
and you,
you,
you have a strong mushroom trip,
man.
It just strips you down.
You see what they describe as
the wiring under the board.
You know,
you see things in a different perspective.
It's,
it's,
it's an impossible perspective.
It shouldn't be.
First of all,
it shouldn't exist and second of all,
it shouldn't be so easy to get to.
All you have to do is eat this stuff.
You eat this stuff and wait an hour and
20 minutes and all of a sudden you're
literally in an impossible describe
different world that shouldn't exist.
It can't be real because it violates
everything you know about life.
When you're closing your eyes,
everywhere you look is
more and more impossible.
And there's information coming at you
all the answers to all the world's
problems,
but it's like slippery fish and you're
standing in a river and you can't fucking
hold on to many of it.
There's just too many
fucking fish coming your way,
man.
And there's the water and the information
is hitting you like the fucking river.
You're selling the game or some.
Again,
it's not for everybody,
but it's for you.
That's what I say.
It's not for everybody,
but it's for you.
There's great men who have
learned incredible things
from psychedelic trips and
there's a guy named Graham Hancock who
was going to be doing the podcast soon.
He contacted me in email.
I just emailed him back and he says,
genius writer who wrote these fascinating
books about ancient human history
called the fingerprints of the gods.
It's a all about these ancient
structures that point to uh,
the v very plausible idea that the human
race has been around way longer than
we'd like to thank.
And that civilization has had peaks and
valleys where we were almost wiped out
and we had to rebuild a new and he claims
that they're kinda like what you were
talking about before,
like returned to the cities and be
like where are these buildings come?
Sure.
But when his case it was more of like,
I think what he there they're mostly
pointing towards giant cataclysmic
disasters that have,
you know,
all but wiped out a huge percentage of
the human race and then people have to
start all over again.
I mean the concept of what if today,
okay,
in 2011 like the Matrix third
metrics movie was that it was that,
was that what happened
in the theater majors?
They were like this is,
you know,
permutation of a fucking equation that
it's essentially the message was this
happened,
there's the 16th time we've done this.
Like we keep running you guys and
to turn to you guys is based yeah,
that's based on an ancient Hindu system
or it's an Indian system called the
[inaudible].
That's I think,
I don't know the full thing.
Our friend Duncan's an
expert in this shit.
But what do you,
the way he explained it to me is that
this is Kali Yoga and the Kali Yoga is
like the,
the most chaotic stage
of the human existence.
And we have this normal
natural progression from like,
you know,
sensible to wild,
the crazy to completely out of control,
which is where we are now.
And to the next stage is some
sort of an enlightenment,
some sort of a learning from this,
some sort of a,
a next passage that goes through.
And then the idea is that we're that
humanities in this continuous cycle and
that it's,
you know,
we like to think of ourselves,
it hasn't having a direct
linear projection from
monkey to human being in 2011
but in fact it may have hit this peak
thousands and thousands and thousands of
years ago and then been shut down by
some horrible disaster that killed almost
everybody and that almost
everybody forgets about it
because you kill like half
the fucking people and mandate,
you know,
w w good luck,
good luck piecing things together,
writing things down.
You know,
paper gets d disappears.
They burned the library of Alexandria,
they all saw the records for Egypt.
Everything they have left to just shit
carved in snow or it carved in stone.
Rather.
It's like,
you know,
you want to really get the
full history of the human race.
It's really complicated.
It's like we don't really know
what happened 10,000 years ago.
We don't really know what happened 15
20,000 and in the course of the universe
or the course of the life of this planet,
that's a fucking half
of a blink of the eye.
It's almost like as a race,
we have woken up at a certain level
where we started writing things down like
we'll call it a thousand years ago,
whatever the fuck it was,
where people really started
writing things down.
It's almost like we're just slowly
piecing this fucking thing together.
As it's moving,
it's moving into the reaction.
People just starting to write things down,
okay,
this is what happens in
this and this and this.
Then the next people come along and go,
okay,
they already figured this out.
Okay,
what else can we figure it out?
Then we got to figure this out and they're
all moving along as life is moving,
constantly trying to Riyadh to
this fucking pile of awakening.
I try to describe this life that were
just born in the middle of mid momentum,
hit the ground running.
As soon as you could walk your golf to
school and you're a fucking cog in the
wheel boom and,
and you know,
and very little time to sit down and
think about what the fuck it really is.
The notion of a,
it's all occurring.
Like we're waking up the renaissance
of sorts when somebody writing it down,
number one,
I thought that was really sweet,
but number two,
the notion of doing that
while you're moving,
like moving forward still,
you can't stop time and tell people like,
wait,
let me catch up and write everything down.
So far.
Yeah.
Like they,
you'd have to start fucking swimming.
You're absolutely right.
That's kind of evocative.
That was a really beautiful image.
Well done.
Thanks.
Yeah,
I'm a writer.
I appreciate it.
Some good words,
but as well done.
You took me right fucking there.
You sold the game mean,
but that is what,
that is what we're doing,
right?
Yeah.
We try to think,
I don't know,
boy,
now you're making the
move in one direction.
The human.
If you just look at the idea that
we're constantly creating new things,
constantly trying to
improve on the technology,
it's Kinda reached some fucking nuts
point sometime in the future
when machines take over.
Yeah,
man,
this Kurt's wheel Rickerts wields.
He's one of those futurists that believes
in it as a lot of other guys who have
a very unroll the prediction.
You know,
there's a lot of people that,
you know,
think that we have been so desensitized
by the Terminator being a movie,
right?
But we think it's silly that we don't
recognize that this is a fucking real
problem at skynet.
Could be.
And what do we,
what are we thinking that we're going
to create something that's going to have
autonomy.
We're going to create
something that has a,
you were gonna want to know
if it can turn itself on.
We're going to want to figure that out.
We're going to want to know if we can
make something like a repair itself.
We're gonna want to know if we can
make something that can clone itself,
given enough time with human
beings monkeying around with shit.
We're eventually going to hit that point,
man.
You're talking about singularity?
Yeah,
it's an instant evitable
it seems in our lifetime.
It's a captivating,
the
notion,
I read the,
I forget either time or Newsweek
did a wonderful article on it,
but the way they described it though,
it was very evocative
and as much as they said,
think about how like the first computer,
you know,
fill a couple rooms and it's equating
power wasn't even a 10th of what your
phone can do right now.
And that was going back to what,
how years ago was that?
50 60 years ago.
Yeah.
So in that piece they said,
imagine what's going to
be in 30 years from now.
From this moment.
No,
there's like this phone exist,
the phone,
the computer,
the outs,
outs with a piece.
I mean Steve Jobs said it
himself a couple of months back.
He was like,
when he was talking about doing the cloud,
he's like,
the hardware's not the,
the sole anymore.
It's just a conduit and whatnot.
It's not going to be ring tones.
You know the future's going to be,
you going to be able
to talk to each other.
I'm going to be able to go,
dude,
where are you?
And people are going to get upset
if you don't let them do that.
Like girls are going to get upset.
Why can't I just talk to you
whenever I want to talk to you?
What?
Like shining.
Yeah,
like you want this?
You want no,
you want the fucking cell phone.
You want the ring?
You want to ring so you can look at it
and decide whether or not to answer but
if someone can make the cell phone rang.
I thought you were saying like in the
future we won't need phones talking to it
might not even have to be a phone.
It might not.
You're right.
It might not even have to be a phone,
but I think initially it's going
to start out with ringtones.
The first thing that's going to be
the dams gonna break is instead of a
ringtone.
Why?
Why can't they set it up so I
can talk to you in the ringtone?
Hey Kevin,
it's me.
Joe,
pick up the phone,
dude,
I,
this is fucking super important.
I hate to be bugging you,
but pick up the phone.
Almost like an answering Michigan prereqs.
That's what you're hearing.
When the phone rings,
you're hearing your friend say,
dude,
pick up the fucking phone right now.
Almost like old school answering machine.
You know,
that will be the first option.
And people would get
that because they'll say,
honey,
what if it's an emergency and this some
shit goes down and I need to get in
touch with you.
Yeah,
you're right.
Okay.
And then people go,
what the fuck?
Where are you bitch?
I'm fucking calling you right now.
I'm going to keep calling you
every fucking dude and you'll,
you'll be able to harass that person.
Literally yell at them until they
shut their fucking phone off.
That that will be step one.
And then eventually there
will be no more phone.
They're gonna figure out some way,
whether it's a neural
implants or you know,
yeah,
I think it's neural implants.
Well,
implying
30 years from now,
the phone will be
insertable into your head.
This is a tiny,
it'll be like this.
And there's that material.
What does it call this?
The shit that's like as
thin as Saran fiber optics.
I don't know if that's it.
This is new material.
It's about thin as a,
probably can't be that new
fiber optics is old as fuck.
That's it.
And I don't think it's
that I'm talking to myself.
It's then like they showed a piece of,
it looks like a piece of Saran wrap,
but it's the strength of it
is like fucking concrete,
like 16 layers of concrete.
And they're saying it also
has fold ability so you can
roll it up and bundle it
up and it's also made of sand or whatever,
you know,
fucking silicon.
So it's conductive.
So they're saying,
imagine you had or like this.
Yeah,
this looks Kinda so,
I don't know what these are,
but these ties,
is that what it is?
Um,
I want to smell it.
If you had this and you could do this
with it or you could just roll it up real
tight and stick it in your ear,
this would be your phone.
They're like,
shape is no longer a problem.
Like this is the material.
It's like when you watched
the fucking Batman begins,
he's got that memory cloth for the Cape
or little electric charge to it in a
titans.
Same thing here.
They only let,
you don't need to tighten it.
They're like,
it's all flexible.
Everything,
all the conductors are inside.
So it will do exactly what it
needs to have that for a armor,
for motorcycle riders.
Now I know,
I think they'll have some
shit when you hit the ground.
The impact of like
flattens it out it hard.
I,
yeah,
I don't know if that's in testing
or if that's actually a good sale.
I saw that video.
But one of the things they've come out
recently with and a know a lot of people
say like,
man,
you guys always talk
about the fucking soon.
You already know.
Tell her to hearing this.
Like that's like number one
complaint in the podcast.
And I admit it because I
fucking drone on about it.
Why?
Because I a gang.
Yeah.
And when I see things like this,
okay.
Look,
artificial skin made from spider silk.
Yes.
Bullet proof.
Isn't that amazing,
dude?
I'm going to get bulletproof scan.
It's going to be awesome.
I can't wait until this is legal.
I'm going to get a full bar.
They're going to skin me.
They're going to try to
keep me alive by the skin.
Me.
And then they replace your
skin with bulletproof.
Spiders get silk skin.
How crazy is it?
How many people are going
to sign up for that?
You don't want to be an early adoptee.
It's like fake lips.
Read the ingredient.
Wait until they get that shit down.
You know,
he didn't want to fucking big
stitches under your armpits.
Yeah,
they live giant fuck and scars,
Dude.
I like my new skin.
It's bulletproof and everything,
but a fucking hate.
The scars read how they make it too.
That's goat's milk.
They put the enzyme or they weren't,
you know,
gee,
they fucked with the genetics.
The DNA,
if you will.
It's amazing,
man of this weird goat's milk and
made it like more like spiders.
So whatever the Goco,
you know,
whatever they milk out of the goat.
They spin into this fucking
hardest substance there that help.
I was stronger than Kevlar.
Dope is nature.
Yeah.
This crazy little giant
little fucking insect thing.
This weird abdomen produces this shit.
There was a line and
then this great Batman,
oh,
it was a swamp thing.
Issue that Batman was in years
ago that Alan Moore wrote.
We're swamp thing.
You know,
he's an elemental,
he's,
you know,
get the power of nature
on a side and whatnot.
Big swamp thing.
Fan back in the Disney.
So,
uh,
he attacks Gotham.
They have his woman,
they've tied up Abby Arcane,
they've kept her in jail.
They've arrested her because she's
cohabitated with the vegetative.
A humanoid.
Really?
Yeah,
the swamp thing.
And so they put her in jail.
She was supposed to be arrested in
Houma and they arrest restaurant,
Gotham and stead and swamp thing is like,
we want to release.
And they were like,
we can't,
she's,
you know,
she committed a crime,
she's going to be healthier
on trial and whatnot.
And swamp thing takes a
slowly ticks over Gotham.
He warns them,
you know,
he just appears from
like can make himself,
as you know,
out of any vegetative material whatsoever.
It turns into a giant head and it's just
like release the woman or I will take
the city,
you know,
and the end,
the one issue with part one of like,
you know,
you see Gotham start falling into jungle.
Like he just over vegetated everything
and people just go back to fucking
nature.
He takes the,
takes the city and turns
it back into the jungle.
In the last panel is a high
view of all this of course.
And standing on a Gargoyles,
the one motherfucker who does
not want anything to go back
to the jungle and it's Batman.
Powerful fucking book.
But at one point,
second issue,
swamp thing has this line where he
goes to us like if nature but shrugged,
you'd be all,
you'd all be gone or something
very powerful like that.
But it's the if nature but shrug line
that always got me cause he was talking
about we think we command everything.
We think we're,
we've mastered shit we know are dumb.
But it's just that you've talked about
before a cataclysmic event that wipes out
half the planet or something like that.
That's if nature but shrugs.
It happens out here.
You know,
when we feel the tremors,
the earthquakes were reminded all the
time that surface fleas as George Carlin
described as,
um,
but when you see nature going
crazy with the weather and whatnot,
and you start sitting there going,
oh,
like,
do you remember that George Carlin bit
where he talked about how the planets
find the people are fucked,
him and his legendary bit.
But you know,
he starts theorizing on like the planet
trying to pick us off with disease and
shit like that.
Um,
and,
and you start seeing every
time I see a natural disaster,
it's all I could think about it.
I was just like the
planets after us again,
they found the world's largest
pyramid by volume in Guatemala,
expectantly they founded
a couple of years ago.
It's enormous by volume,
like a cigarette.
Whereas the pyramid,
it's like a Mayan pyramid.
You know,
the Mayan Pyramids,
they weren't smooth like
the Egyptian pyramids,
but they all went into that
same shape essentially.
Well,
they found it in Guatemala,
covered in jungle.
I mean,
this is just a totally lost,
amazing civilization covered in jungle.
And they think there might be thousands
of these thousands of these all
throughout South America,
thousands of lost temples and pyramids.
This incredible civilization that existed
that made these immense structures in
a place that's so nuts that the,
the jungle just overgrew everything to
the point where they thought it was a
mountain,
they thought it was a mountain and they
start excavating it and find out it's
the biggest fucking pyramid by
volume on earth when it does happen.
2009 apparently they had it on CNN.
I was a,
somebody just posted it
recently and I tweeted it.
It's a a,
it says though,
the thing on Youtube is world's largest
pyramid discovered like they lost this
whole thing.
Man.
People had moved out of there so much
to the point where there was nothing
living there.
It was just trees and the whole thing
just filled with grass and trees and
someone had a come along thousands of
years later and kick something over and
go,
what's this?
Dig a little hole.
Hey Man,
this is a brick.
Hey,
bring over shovel and the next
thing you know they're like,
what the fuck is this?
Slowly way up to imagine what that means.
That experience must be like a
finding something like that as well.
We have a phenomenal,
I mean,
well,
well it's the top
set of whatever Geraldo Rivera felt.
Oh Fund up Al Capone's
vault and was like nothing.
There's nothing in here.
But the shock that this
could be left behind.
The shock for this is,
you know,
thousands of years ago,
can't even really wrap
our heads around that.
They built this shit and it all went
bad and the fucking jungle overtook the
land.
You know,
you go Atlanta's to go as
far back as Atlantis or no,
do I believe in Atlanta?
So there's some,
some archeologists that believe
they founded off of Spain.
In fact,
they have concentric rings that they've
found in a satellite view of the ocean.
They somehow or another that you know,
they can,
they can see like the topography of the
ocean from space and in the satellite
view they found this place that
literally matches the geography,
matches the area that it would be
matches the local layer matches.
You know,
there's,
there's folk layer that
that is attached to it.
You know,
that you could be attributed to history.
you can tell you the actual history.
So they believe that
they have found Atlantis.
What Ha,
what had happened to it.
It just does.
This place was a also
very subject to tsunamis.
It's had many tsunamis before and they
think that's most likely what happened
was that,
you know,
these people lived on a part of the sea,
they had an advanced civilization.
It got really prosperous,
but they weren't aware yet of
tsunamis and Chet along those lines,
like if you go a few thousand
years without a tsunami,
it's not unheard of.
It could mean can hope the world because
what hasn't happened in a few thousand
years that we're aware of and
suddenly it's going to happen again.
Well,
especially on the west coast,
man.
I mean,
we know that some big ones if hit I
believe up in as far north as like Seattle
and Portland,
Oregon,
uh,
hundreds of years ago,
that place got fucked up by tsunamis.
It's real possible.
I mean,
the ocean is gigantic
and it's right there.
But if,
uh,
if my point is that if a few hundred
years go by and there's no tsunami,
that's not unusual.
So if this civilization was allowed to
prosper and grow in a few hundred years,
it could have been super advanced.
We know that they could do
a bunch of things back in,
you know,
10,000 plus years ago that we
didn't think they could do.
And we're,
we're more and more figuring
out as time goes on,
but they might have been way more advanced
than we ever gave them credit for.
They might've even have telescopes.
Like there's,
there's people that believe that they
found lenses that they get attribute to be
being ground down.
And some say that they're
not strong enough to,
to,
to actually work as a telescope.
But it could have been,
you know,
one of many.
They could have evolved if they came up
with this initial idea and you found a
bad version of it.
Just the fact that they had figured
out that they can make something at a
crystal and look through it,
that's some pretty advanced shit.
What are you looking for?
What are you doing with that?
Is you sure that's just ornamental?
And were they making telescopes?
Were they making microscopes?
What the fuck were they doing?
Were clearly says they're there,
they're examining the unexamined
life is not worth living.
So there were philosophical people,
they weren't,
they were looking for answers.
So it wasn't enough to just be like,
feed me,
feed me sex.
It was enough to be like,
I want to look beyond our world or deeper
into our right and a totally different
way.
They did it from the way we did it,
but we have this whole petrochemical
way of viewing the world and we think
that's the only way to do it.
And it may not be.
They may be that there's
some civilizations that
have reached some staggering
heights without the use of that and we
just don't know how the fuck they did it.
We need,
and we don't know how.
They moved a lot of the great stones
to make giant structures throughout
history.
That's this great Graham Hancock,
that's like his specialty
on this thing and he,
he wrote a book called supernatural all
about his experiences with his IOWASCA.
This drinking is brew and all his
experiences with psychedelics and how
empowering they've been to him and how
he believes that it's very likely that
they are the source of,
of human,
a human culture and human knowledge
and human growth and it's shorter than
social source of self awareness that
it probably started with psychedelic
experiences and it's an,
he's not the only one to say this.
Mckenna believed it.
As I said before,
a lot of people echo it,
but I just think,
I think everyone who's creative,
everyone who is an artist,
everyone who is a thinker,
you deserve to go through an experience
with someone who knows what they're
doing.
That's why it should be legal and there
should be shamans and there should be
someone who runs a center that
can evaluate whether or not,
first of all,
you're psychologically capable
of handling such an experience,
but give you the proper dosage,
keep you supervision.
It should be something that people
encourage because it makes you a better
person.
Mm.
I'm back in the day that person existed,
he was the medicine man or Shelman.
Yeah,
in the Amazon.
Right now,
the guys who make the ILS Osca well,
well,
I can't,
I'm,
you know,
I guess there's no money in shamanism.
Is that why there's two tricky,
no,
there's no money in it.
If there was money,
they put you in jail.
If you started getting
money for being a showman,
they'll fucking lock you up.
What are you doing?
Shaman?
What?
What are you getting?
We would have given these fucking people,
lock them up.
Chamonix check his house.
Shammo I feel what?
Uh,
yeah,
I guess you can't practice.
Know what Madison even
especially holistic medicine,
they get weird.
First of all,
I guarantee you on Twitter tonight,
you will be getting thousands of
people telling you to do mushrooms.
Yeah,
no doubt that's going to happen.
I'm telling you,
you've got to look,
I'm 41.
You've gotten me a lot
closer than anybody else.
Like my wife,
who I've been married
to and fucking for 12,
and respect to bond with your team.
You aren't getting laid.
Every problem.
I told me years ago,
she's like,
you would really love mushrooms.
I can't believe you've
never done mushrooms.
She's like,
we should get mushrooms
and do them together.
One Desk.
I don't think I could go.
You're a very unusual thinker
and I think it would only
aid in your thought process.
It'd be fascinating.
You're sold down to earth as it is.
Dude.
You're such a normal guy.
Like,
um,
I don't know how you managed to
navigate the entire system of,
and you're in the movie system,
which I think is even more
ridiculous than my system.
My system.
I'm on the fringes.
I'm in like fucking,
you know,
sports commentary and standup comedy.
That's really what,
and occasionally fear factor.
That's my um,
fringed you're deep
into the belly of bullshit,
but it's amazing that
you've been able to do that.
It's amazing.
Even embark with alias actors,
you just have to give up ego and you'd
have to be willing to accept less.
You've got to manage your expectations.
Something I learned by being
in my wife all these years,
this was a chick who didn't
want to marry a fat guy,
but she met one who she really liked.
He is good and all other
ways except for that one,
she managed her expectations
and it all worked out for you.
You know what I'm saying?
She's like,
Oh God can,
I can deal with that.
But the rest of the package good.
You manage your expectations and
you can do that sort of thing.
So for me,
I always try to keep the ego in check,
manage the expectations,
expectations in this business or everyone
should be paying attention to me.
I should be the epicenter of
everything and I'm what's hot and blah,
blah,
blah.
And I've always accepted the fact
that that was never going to be me.
So it was always content to just dwell
out here on the fringes and when you're
hired on the fringes that it's,
I wouldn't say you're incorruptible,
but it is,
people aren't that interested
in corrupting you and,
and you can also watch the corruption
go on deep in the center of the bullshit
as you say.
And so while you're kind of not
above it but just outside of it,
it's a lot easier to see it
happening and stay away from it.
When you see a movie like Conan,
do you go,
oh that must have been a
mass to work on and now I,
when I see it I was just the,
I see,
I mean I didn't see it,
but if I saw a movie like
Kona and I'd be like,
Oh man,
could you imagine how many people
put in so much time into this?
And then it didn't take off like that's,
I see the expense is all
I see now is the money.
I watch any movie and I'm just like,
oh perfect.
Conan too though could have done it.
Should have done it.
Why didn't that work?
Did.
I saw that trailer and I was just like,
all right,
I'm a huge fan of the Arnold Kona and
that was my cone and I didn't even,
I wasn't aware of they were making the
Cornell movie until I saw the trailer.
I was like,
what the fuck?
Why would anyone bother?
And I watched it.
I was like,
Oh,
you know what?
This is a lot closer to the real Kona
m and fucking Arnold Schwarzenegger.
It was very close.
It just got stupid too many times.
It just lost it went off the track and
into the woods too many times was that
dude as a character was great.
He would've been an awesome Conan in
the under the right direction with the
right script.
But I wrote a red rather a something
that the guy who made it wrote and he
talked about as original script and
how it got butchered all the way.
And that's make sense.
Like when you see something
so disjointed where so much,
so many parts of it were awesome.
Like the little kid in the
beginning that was fucking bad ass.
You didn't see him for the new Kona.
Yeah.
He didn't see the Newtonian yet save it.
But if you do see it,
this part is what I,
a huge fan of the Old Komeito
while I'm a robbery Howard fan man.
So you go back deeper as,
all right.
So as a Howard Fan,
did you see uh,
what was that movie about him with
Renee Zellweger and you know what,
that's an offer.
He bought that movie.
I have it in the back of my fucking shelf,
my DVD shelf,
and I've never watched one
of those world if I forget.
Yeah.
But anyway,
if as a fan,
as a Howard fan,
did you like the Arnold's
Conan or did you feel like,
is it like a reading the shining
book versus the coopers shining?
It's like they cartoon
to find it for sure.
The CONAN was much more ruthless and
brutal and bloody and it was way crazy.
Like I say soft and Tim,
you feel oh yeah.
Both of them softened him.
Yeah.
I mean he was,
he was,
uh,
you know,
like it was a compassionate guy
and he always did the right thing.
But he was fucking hack and
heads off left and right.
I mean,
it was just a mean.
He was just a barbarian making its way
through magic and sorcery and monsters
and fucking hordes of ogres and I mean,
they were just crazy ass
fucking wild stories.
Robert Howard was a bad motherfucker,
but he was ultimately crazy and one
of them blown in his own brains out.
I think it was like 36 or
something was a whole wide world.
That's the name of the movie,
I think the wholesale what it is.
Yeah.
He killed himself.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He just was so into his fucking his,
his world of fantasy.
We so good at it,
but his real life just sucked.
Man is real life.
He just was miserable.
He hated it.
And he made this character this with
whatever pain that he was going through in
his real life.
He poured it into this
character being powerful.
You know,
it's just dumb.
He,
they weren't just straight
Scifi fantasy books.
There were so consistent.
Right.
You know,
they were,
there was some great ones,
man,
I fucking loved him.
You would buy him the paper bags with
the Frank Frazetta fucking oil paintings
on the cover of him.
Holy Shit.
You know,
I mean those were books,
man.
That was some amazing shit that
you read the comics as well.
Yeah,
I did.
One of my saddest moments in my life
is when I was so poor when I was a
struggling comedian that I had
to sell all my comic books,
which was sold everything I
sold my Spiderman is my Conan's,
mostly marvel at marvel.
And then I had a lot
of like creepy and ear.
He,
you know,
those uh,
independent magazines.
You make rent,
just rent it for a month.
Barely.
I've probably got some food.
I got 150 bucks for everything.
And I mean,
you're talking to years of collecting
and the guy was totally screwed me,
but I needed the money.
It's probably hard to sell,
man,
you know?
I mean,
he's probably got to go through a lot.
He needs to make some money off of it.
I've put together,
we're trying to make clerks,
I don't know.
I was going to need money to make it.
And I was a big comic book fan.
I hadn't been collecting
a hardcore for that long,
was more all modern age stuff.
I didn't go back and buy
any golden or silver age,
but still I did an evaluation
in that collection man.
It was like,
I don't know,
20,000 and change or whatever,
$20,000 with the comic books based
on the book value book value.
So I said,
okay,
I'm going to go into,
yeah,
of course over over maybe Overstreet
I might've used on that point.
Um,
so I go,
okay,
this collection,
then I'll sell it for 10 k.
And so I go to a bunch of comp look a it
shows and a bunch of comic book dealers
and stores.
And this is 1991,
92,
let's say nine,
no,
93 94 cause no 92 93 92.
And I give him my full
catalog of everything I have
with all the prices next to
it,
all the,
you know,
the guide prices and then the wrap
up of 10,000 bucks like you know,
and it's a collection that's worth
more than that you can have for 10 k.
Um,
and nobody of course bit the
only people that bit was um,
this comic book store and in Middletown,
which was called what?
Holy Crap,
I'm getting old and I can't remember,
but in any event they took,
they took my comics,
they gave me $2,000 wait
for it in store credit.
Oh.
So what I would do is sell my store
credit to my friend Walt flat again.
I'd be like,
you go in comics plus that's
what the name of the store,
you go in Cox plus you buy $100 where
the comics used my credit then give me 80
bucks cash.
So he was always getting like 20% off.
So I wasn't even getting the fall two k.
Wow.
Yeah.
Dang.
But it made it paid for clerks.
So there you go.
Paid for a few bills that paid for
clerks until Miramax pick clerks up.
And then there was that.
So,
you know,
I had never felt bad letting
go to collection because
it ultimately financed the
thing that made everything else possible.
And then years later,
you know,
I just figured like if I want the books,
I go back and get them.
And I collected the ones I did want again.
But then years later I just bought a
complex touring that was like buying a lot
of comic book store.
Yeah.
I got one in Red Bank,
New Jersey called Jane's
Bob's secret stash.
We have one out here in
Westwood for a little while,
but my friend got bored or running
it and then we wound up shattering.
But the one back east has been
open since like 97 that podcast.
Tell Him Steve,
David and my friends got
the show of on AMC that uh,
that they record that at that comp.
How much better our comic books on weed.
I've,
I haven't really written,
I haven't read one yet.
I've written a bunch and there's
so much more fun to ride on weed.
So you haven't read any since
you've been smoking weed?
No,
I've been in a real non audience
mode for the last few years.
I don't,
I don't read as much as I used to.
I don't watch TV as much as I did.
Just create your own shit.
I've been on a real creation Jag
and you know it comes and goes.
I think in cycles,
the old long you stick around,
the more he realized that like creatively
fertile and like in the early part of
my career and then I get into career
management middle of the career and pay
perhaps not as fertile.
The ideas aren't as cool.
Maybe you start thinking more about like,
well I got to eat,
I got to make sure I got
another job after this,
but now I'm back into a creatively fertile
period where it's just like I'm going
to try this,
let me try this and that.
You get a certain amount
of respectability,
we can really do whatever you want.
Yeah,
I think so.
That's what you hit.
That's why I'm like,
you're crazy to say
that you're not famous,
but I have,
it's the name and I never
thought of it as kid.
Doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
It's all nonsense.
But what's important is the,
you're doing something very
different though though.
The whole way you're doing it,
the way you're doing it
with constantly being,
putting out these podcasts mean you know,
just doing a podcast like this.
You realize like how much of
who you are you put out there.
I mean you just,
you putting it out there
every day like that.
It's about how bottomless
we are in terms of like,
if you can think about how many podcasts
you've done a couple that with all this
standup,
you've done a couple that with every
real conversation you ever shared with
somebody in your fucking life
and you're still not done,
you still have so much more to say.
We're,
we're unfathomably deep human beings
are deep creatures who can keep finding
things to talk about.
We talk because what else is there if
we're not communicating with ourselves
with each other,
what are we doing here?
Especially now with the Internet.
I mean that's the big difference
between now and 20 years ago world.
That's why I say 20 years
ago I'd be fucking freaking
out that I didn't have the
Internet cause the come,
you can choose the community you choose
to communicate the community that you
interact with and I bet you find,
even though you have a lot of
fucking people and your Twitter,
I bet you find they're predominantly cool,
aren't they?
Yes.
Across the board.
So that's why I love Twitter
because it's so positive.
Everything.
Your fans feel good.
Yeah.
You have 1,800,000 plus of
your fans tuned into you.
We could tell them things and you could
clue them in on stuff all the time and
they're excited and happy.
It's all positive.
They're predisposed to
say something positive.
All of course you get the
random sniper jackass.
But generally it's just like,
oh my God,
I just watched clerks and it was great.
And you know,
I've never seen it before
or I had a real shitty day.
Listen to the podcast feel great.
Thanks.
Are you know the today has
been the last two days?
Well,
I mean last week,
two weeks when with the Canadian tour,
but the last day,
like not even full day
last 12 hours red state,
but on VOD since I woke up this morning,
which was about,
I think I got up at four Ivr.
Ironically I wake up
around four 20 every day.
I got up around fourish and it started
reading positive feedback is people can
watch it on Vod,
at their fucking house,
on their computer because
people are watching it,
tweeting me while they're
watching it and do it.
It's like a,
it's like a never ending series of
great job patting you on the back.
Like I said,
I was saying before,
it costs nothing to encourage
an artist and the yield,
the potential yield is,
it is indescribable.
Think about it.
You,
you encourage an artist one day they
write that song that becomes that most
important song in the world to you on
that day that your parent fucking dies.
The song that says it all,
that you'll always be dialed into.
They were that person
maybe writes a blog that,
oh,
puts the shit you always wanted to say
right into perspective and new meme it
out to everybody.
It's your becomes your mantra.
They make movie that you know is
that movie that changed your life,
whatever,
man.
There's all upside to
encouraging an artist.
Nothing good comes from the flip side,
discouraging an artist.
Now people be like,
well,
you should discourage some fucking artists
like you wee bowl or some were Kevin
Smith I or the ELA.
Well,
Shit.
You know what I'm saying?
There's nothing bad.
Nothing good comes from that.
You tell some of the are you stink,
don't do it anymore.
What are they gonna do?
They stop and maybe they don't.
Maybe you don't like them,
but maybe they don't inspire somebody
else or make somebody else think,
hey,
I can try it.
You say that,
but what about the concept of the salmon
needing a waterfall to climb up to
ensure that the strong gene survive
and if every person had told you,
Oh fuck Kevin Smith,
those haters fueled you and gave you
extra inspiration to push further.
Highlight that if these are
like your work like that.
No,
I try not to.
It's definitely a negative way to do it.
I know a lot of fighters
use that as motivation.
I had think you have to
in that lot of sliders,
like they're his ears and also,
but think about it as a fighter.
You have to get over.
I know you said that primal
brain somewhere in there,
but you got to get over the brain that
we've been dealing with for so many
years,
which is like don't get hurt,
don't go in there,
don't,
don't run from danger protections.
So,
so right then and there,
that's why it's so exciting
differently than anybody else.
They're going over
their program like dove,
right?
They're rewiring
going in a different way and they have
to try to stay zen in the moment and not
freak out.
And let it,
the adrenaline and everything just
overwhelmed them and go into full panic.
We had Shandling,
Garry Shandling was on the,
on our,
on our show it the house
one day and he was talking,
he likes to box a big box and he was
talking about almost the same thing you
were in terms of like you're there,
they're not there it is.
So it's about being there and letting
go and it's an accounts out of you or he
was describing a half,
I forget how I described it in terms of
like just not being where the punch is
going to be and knowing that sooner or
later you will get punched but the more
you're in this moment
like you eat once again,
it's,
so what I find fascinating about as people
who can find or people getting a ring
physical and not just like,
oh we play some pickup basketball ship,
but usually people get
into boxing fighting.
They can be so poetic about it cause you
are channeling into something I guess
that most people don't.
We don't live in a world where we'd go
around fighting people or getting into
physical altercations involving our body.
So I think you guys do dial into
something because everyone he is,
when you describe it for just a second,
I go like,
yeah man,
I should fucking fight.
But I know I am not that guy.
Like in a minute I get in the
ring and be fucking taking,
you know,
the thought of getting hit would
make me queasy and I pass out.
But fighters,
people that do it,
people you know who've who've actually
been in a ring and and and fought or
continue to do it or so poetic about it
that they can almost sell you on it to
the point of like,
wow,
I should give that a shot,
but I know I'm not made for being
hit I one head and I'm gone.
It's not for everybody
and nothing's forever.
Right.
But what it really sounds like you want,
you want it to be for you because
you listen to and go like,
oh my God.
Like,
could you imagine being zen with about
fighting about being there and not being
there in that ring about having to,
having to zone out,
but be very present so as
not to get fucking killed?
Yeah,
by choice and you have to learn how
to harness all of your potential,
everything together,
psychological,
physical.
You got to tune it all together.
You've got to make sure that your
mind doesn't overwhelm your body with
information.
You've got to make sure that you keep
your heart rate steady and stay calm and
see things exactly as they are.
Not exaggerated because
you're under some adrenaline,
heightened fear.
You've got to keep it together,
man,
but what it really is is a vehicle for
developing your human potential martial
arts or something.
Anything that's really difficult,
man.
I think anything that's really,
really,
really fucking hard to do in doing so,
you learn a lot about yourself while
you're doing it and you learn about your
potential.
You learn what you could
push yourself through.
You learn how much focus you have in you.
You learn how to project it,
how to keep it strong,
had to keep it going,
had to stay,
you know,
stay heightened,
stay in a heightened state.
And that's what you,
you get from that you learned excellence,
you know,
for anything.
Whether it's martial arts are fucking
playing a violin or anything when Shit's
really difficult to do.
You,
you learn something about yourself in it.
Mastery of it leads to mastery
by the things in your master's.
What was the quote you said?
Once you understand the way broadly you
can see it in all things beautiful and
especially from a bad motherfucker
chopping people up with a sword.
Yeah.
I mean normally you get kind of that,
that homespun wisdom from you know,
a little bald man who sits,
who's Chubby,
who sits on a hill.
But this dude's like,
no,
I,
I know a lot about life cause I ended
so fucking many of so sweetly slice of a
razor like sword across the knack and
wants the head separate from the body and
like a fall down lovers kiss is body
twitches before it falls in a couple of
spurts of blood come out of the blow
hole at the top and then it crumbles.
Couple UNC,
you're a,
you're making things awkward.
That's it.
That's the end of the podcast folks.
This is the longest podcast
in the history of podcasts.
How long we going you really get
through all four hours if you really get
through it all ladies and gentlemen,
God bless you.
You're beautiful iTunes,
we're probably going to have to chop this
up into part one and part two is going
to take a walk because
I get that big of a fan.
I don't want anybody her
while we do the show monitor.
Like in terms of can you read feedback?
Do you have like we did that before
but it was always nigger cunt,
nigger con,
uh,
lesser.
Whilst a lot of people just trying to
buy Twitter I use Twitter is awesome.
Yeah,
like Twitter,
I'll,
I'll monitor while we do the show.
When there's a chat and
you want people like,
people want to like send you
something that you'll read.
They'll just say the most obscene,
ridiculous,
retarded shit.
So there was like a lot of people
doing that flooding things.
I was wondering if anyone,
here we go,
just listen to Kevin Smith and
Joe Rogan mindblowing podcast.
That's it.
Can I get my old song back man?
No Dude,
you gotta go with the,
with the eight bit versions.
No Way.
The committee version,
man,
I want to make a version of the
last four minutes of free bird.
Can we do that?
Can we make that my new interviewee?
I just want the last four minutes.
Just the last four.
Yeah.
A free bird.
Freebird Leonard's Kennard.
Hmm.
You know that,
that
[inaudible]
and you know where the end comes.
I don't even have it on this.
Ladies and gentlemen,
it's been an amazing podcast.
I've had a great time.
If you're still alive out there,
if you're awake,
if you haven't listened to us and driven
your fucking car off the road and into
the woods because we draw
dotted on for four hours.
I'm sorry I had anybody out there.
Anybody at all remember
that fucking day after.
Yeah,
and I was a kid.
They did this,
this TV movie about nuclear work as we
were all afraid about dying nuclear war.
Stop,
drop and roll.
Yes.
But they made this movie called the
day after on ABC and they were like,
viewer discretion is advised.
Like when that deep voice guy came into
play first and they were telling you,
it was like,
this is intense.
This is no joke.
This is what could happen if
America witnesses or feel,
you know,
get,
feels the effects of a nuclear attack.
And they at one point there,
you know on the microphone go,
I'm like,
uh,
this is blah,
blah blah,
wherever we are,
Idaho's anybody out there.
And then,
you know,
they wait for a response.
They'll fucking,
this
is Katie k,
blah,
blah blah.
And Idaho.
Is anybody out there?
Anybody at all?
Oh,
it was so haunting as a kid.
I was like,
could you imagine there's only one to
like 12 people left in this fucking town
and they're trying to reach
other people in the world.
Name enough.
Anybody's fucking left cause they
saw mushroom clouds and shit.
I terrified me as a kid,
but when you were just like,
if anybody's listening
and reminded me of that,
like is anybody out there?
I think it was John Lithgow who said
it to you pulled me back to lift gas
circuit and to bitch.
That's how class you are
so kind of performer.
You are.
That's amazing folks.
This has been an awesome time.
I had his grants.
I'm honored.
Thanks.
I'm really honored to be your friend.
It's cool.
It's fun.
Likewise.
Let's do it again anytime you want to do.
I said,
but you're busy.
There's way too and you are.
You've got a thousand things going on,
but I said last time you want,
when we were in my thing,
I said,
I want to do a podcast
every week with Rogan,
just called centered where we
just get stoned and they go.
That's called the Joe Rogan experience.
That's what they do.
I was like,
oh,
I didn't know where we could combine
our forces dude and I was going to help
you.
We'd legalize and half this country I
know may look like we're sure poster
children for stoners work.
We're productive.
We're well at,
you know,
were well spoken.
I'm about will edge and nice,
well spoken and yeah,
we're nice people.
That's got it going on though too
because you're got the strength to,
well that's the confusing.
Protect us.
Yes we need,
yeah.
We're like,
look,
he's smart,
but look at those guns
were okay behind him.
I flipped the switch.
It's confusing.
I'm confusing people.
All right,
whatever.
What are the fuck?
Thank you very much for coming here.
Back a great time.
It was awesome conversation.
Thank you everybody for all,
all the,
all the love on,
on Twitter and on Facebook
and all that shit.
And I think,
you know,
we're in a rare era,
rare time and this time is what
brought me and you together.
Yeah.
This,
this is crazy Internet we've
got going on here and uh,
I think I'm very happy that it's all free.
We're going to keep it free forever
and don't ever worry about that.
We'll,
I'll,
I'll pay for bandwidth.
We'll figure it out.
This podcast,
you know,
I think one of the best things
about your podcast as well,
it's free.
Free.
That's the model.
You got to get it free for everybody.
They'll pay you back another way.
Exactly.
Now the fine,
but just don't get it up front.
You'll get it on there.
Yeah.
You,
you,
you earn either your place in their life,
you pay as you exited
the free little rascals
that show.
And they were like,
you know,
don't pay pay as you exit.
And they were all worried.
Like,
I think spanky was a god of your mind.
They're never going to
pay the of the show.
As bad as the show was.
They all
that's hippy Bohemian shit man.
That's awesome.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible] thank you to the fleshlight.
If go to Joe rogan.net,
click on the link for the flashlight and
enter in the code named Brogan and you
will get a 15% off the number one sex
toy from Matt and you'll come Holla at
your boy.
And uh,
I have some dates coming up but
I can't read my Twitter page.
What is it?
We got a Washington DC September
30th tickets just went on sale today.
There was a of sale yesterday.
The Warner theater that's good.
Synagogue said goes a nice place.
I like it.
Awesome.
Yeah,
this is the sixth street synagogue,
I think it is.
Oh yeah,
it's literally a synagogue.
It's about 600 seater.
Um,
I did a show there,
a Q and a,
I think last time was in DC.
It was,
it was cool.
We didn't,
that's not what we played red state.
We played red state,
I believe at the,
at the Warner,
but we played,
I did a Q and a at the
synagogue is nice place.
Not you know,
600 seats but it's pretty cool.
Nice.
Cool.
And then a Houston Texas goes
on sale Tuesday salt at all.
You guys go where you going there?
The Verizon Wireless Center
Centre motherfucker I'm going to,
is that bitch?
I Dunno.
It's a couple thousand.
Oh fuck bro.
Look at this guy pulling
out his fucking performance.
What?
I'm just kind of balling now.
What um,
uh,
I,
you know,
I actually,
you should tell you that I started doing
Q and A's at the end of my show is one
of the reasons cause I saw you doing
and I thought it looked cool as fuck on
isn't the ability just to let people
just walk up to you and ask questions.
You know who I saw do it,
stayed with me,
my entire youth,
my grandmothers to watch
Carol Burnett show.
And at the end of the show she'd
stand out there and do Q and A.
Carol Burnett would do that at
the end of her show sketch show.
She did.
I have not every episode,
but like,
and you,
when she did it,
it was fun because like,
she was literally like,
no masks,
no disguise is no costumes.
She's literally came out on stage.
I'm sitting there talking to
the audience and you know,
she'd tug her rear,
say goodbye to her grandmother,
whatever that meant.
But it was,
I dunno,
it was just informal casual and
she seemed so fucking quick.
Like she always had a
great answer and stuff.
And Shandling was on the show when Garry
Shandling was on our show a couple of
weeks ago,
he said that he was talking
to Carol Burnett about,
uh,
about that show.
And she said,
she goes,
um,
to,
you know,
do you know how that worked?
We only used the funny questions.
She whispered it to him like it was a
fucking leg of great recipe or something.
It was like,
oh,
that's hilarious.
But I liked,
I always liked it as a kid.
Like,
that was my favorite part
of that show was like,
oh my gosh,
she's going to literally
talk to the audience,
fill harm you to do that after every
a taping of Newsradio did he really?
Yeah,
he would Q and a with the
audience and do it all the time.
He would ask next time we do this and
we just got talking about farmers could
even do stand up.
He would go out and do impressions
cause he had a crazy Clinton impression,
you know,
uh,
I don't have a small pain is
Monica Lewinsky has a big mouth,
a bunch of,
uh,
like Clinton's should fill as Clinton.
Thank you rob.
And he,
he,
uh,
he would go and do Q and a with the
audience when he was very sharp and very
quick.
And I,
I actually started,
I never,
for the first time with the first season,
I never talked to the audience very much.
I would say hi and whatever,
but I never would do
like stand up for him.
Then after he started doing it,
I was like,
yeah,
we could just fucking fuck
around and talk to the audience.
So Andy would go up and do it
and I would do it and yeah,
it was,
it was a good time.
Just cause like a captive audience.
Be predisposed to like you.
Yeah.
See why you're trained pros,
that's what you do.
And they like it.
It's fun for them.
You know?
It's like all of a sudden this,
we've gone off the,
uh,
the normal pattern of what's going to
happen here tonight and they're just
having a good time.
And yes,
fucking around.
Dude.
You're the shit.
Thank you very much.
But I do this all the time.
This is a new
empire.
We're building together or something,
but I ever blah,
blah blah,
brick by brick weed.
This is the end of this podcast.
Thank you very much for getting here.
And we'll see you soon.
Sunday with Patton Oswald.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we love you bitches.